okay now let's think about what we just
established okay and you can verify this
by actually finding the derivative and
then proving it this point here at the
origin okay it's a stationary point okay
um if i were to draw a tangent would be
horizontal and if you find the gradient
the derivative is 3x squared sure enough
when x equals zero the derivative will
be zero okay
so therefore this is a stationary point
okay but it is not
a turning point
okay because again i'm going to do the
same thing i did over here okay let's
have a look at the gradient here it's
increasing so it's positive
all the way on the left you get to this
one point where the derivative is
negative okay sorry no not negative zero
but then after that it stays positive
so you can see there's no change in sign
and i mean far more you know intuitively
the graph just doesn't turn it doesn't
turn around it'll be like an apple you
throw it up and then it slows down and
then it just decides to keep on going
through the roof you know okay so
yeah that's right it's a
extraterrestrial apple something like
that so
this is not a tiny point okay